at times it was hard to hear the
policies over the bickering but the
leaders were being judged on more than
that pledges in the studio spin room the
press and the party faithful scrutinized
every word and every look and we came up
with our own way to score the debate
would you like to play what we've called
debate Top Trumps we have got some
numbers view to compare the different
performances of the leaders we basically
put them into a nice handy card system
well we've done is we basically watched
the debates watched all the tweets and
we've got our number buds at Sky News to
work out who won on which category so
we've got things like how many chair
interruptions were there how many
audience laughs how many tweets about
the party how many positive post we do
yeah some politicians were more keen
than others to play been a long time
since I paid top you don't know how to
say topshop's it's been oh I do know how
to play many plates but it but you know
I am I stopped playing when I was at
school oh really here's how the leaders
stacked up during the debates the
Conservatives were the most tweeted
about party David Cameron had the
highest percentage of tweets deemed to
be negative by our computer software at
forty five percent that's more than
Farage Clegg and Miliband who all had 42
percentage and it was Nicola Sturgeon
who was the top Trump on positive tweets
twenty-three percent of posts about her
were complementary muscle pleased with
that beautiful absolutely thinking
speaks in fact the social media plays a
big part in our politics now and young
people engaged in people from across the
country engage over a social media so
very pleased to have it very pleased in
a class done so well inside the studio
it was Nick Clegg who was the most
interrupted by the debate chair 11 times
in fact what's going on here we get real
pleased and nigel farage got the most
last from the studio audience with seven
so you're not worried that Nigel Farage
got seven lasting audience and David
Cameron only got one well I think it's
about being a serious person who can
lead the country whichever poles or
stats you look at there are winners and
losers across the board and there's
plenty for the politicians and their
parties to ponder ahead of the next
meeting good game and during your necks
and bring on the lexan that's okay Joe
tidy Sky News